be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
quick discussion about the Living
Tribunal and the one above all and
all-new all-different marvel and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of all
this you'll have a better understanding
of how they fit into the all-new
all-different marvel landscape as well
as how the door remains open for future
retcons regarding their characters it's
so to sidetrack for a second for those
who have not had a chance to see my
videos on these characters which you'll
find down in the description within the
marvel hierarchy prior to Secret Wars
stood the one above all and the Living
Tribunal as the one-two punch what I
mean here is that we're the one above
all was the definitive God having
created the first universe and setting
the development of the multiverse in
motion its role was to function as an
overseer appearing in Fantastic Four
issue number 511 is Jack Kirby and
sensational spider-man as a homeless
person but largely remaining off hands
allowing the Living Tribunal to carry
out functions on its behalf to this end
where the one above all created rules
and regulations to ensure the balance of
the multiverse a living tribunal was
created with astronomical abilities and
served to ensure that no one being
became powerful enough to upset the
cosmic balance as the best example
during the events of Infinity Gauntlet
because then have sought to replace
eternity as a Supreme Being of the
Marvel 6-1-6 universe the Living
Tribunal remained off hands under the
idea that the strong replacing the weak
was the natural order of things
however after the events conclusion
because Adam warlock had sought to use
the gauntlet to impose peace on the
universe because his actions would have
led to all beings losing the freewill
The Living Tribunal stepped in stripping
the gems of their ability to work in
unison and forcing atom to disperse the
gems among those who would use them
justly that said with Marvel organizing
the restructuring of their universe
leading up to secret Wars within the
pages of Jonathan Hickman's run of
Avengers and New Avengers the corpse of
the Living Tribunal was discovered by
The Watcher and iron man keeping the
discovery to themselves in an effort to
avoid a universal panic with a question
went unanswered as to what or who killed
the tribunal at the early part of
hitman's run as the series progressed
leading up to the sort of secret wars
the store revealed that in their effort
to eliminate and reform the multiverse
the beyonders had led a campaign
invading all of the different you
versus killing all the cosmic entities
during this battle which laid waste to
the very fabric of reality itself the
Living Tribunal intervened but was
completely outmatched being obliterated
in the process with a version of itself
landing in every reality leading into
the multi versus final moments with dr.
doom Doctor Strange and molecule man
combining their abilities destroying the
beyonders and absorbing their power
now while the conclusion of Secret Wars
would see dooms defeat by Reed who in
turn harnessed the beyonders power and
reformed the multiverse questions
reigned as to whether or not the one
above all still existed if it did why it
didn't stop the beyonders and whether or
not the Living Tribunal would make its
return answered within the pages of Jim
starlings infinity finale which takes
place after Secret Wars with a story
centering on the villain Annihilus
laying siege to an alternate reality
designated earth 1 4209 and killing the
entirety of that universes hero
population while drawing on the cosmic
energies of Adam warlock and his
attempts to assist in the battle pip the
troll woke at him up which inadvertently
led to Adam absorbing the universe in
its entirety killing all of his
inhabitants but because Thanos was
banished from the realm of mistress
death making it impossible for him to
die Adam warlock called Thanos suicide
in the empty expanse of nothingness
looking for the answer on what would
happen next
referencing the events to Hickman's
lead-up to secret Wars because warlock
had absorbed the essence of his
realities peace of the Living Tribunal
Adam was advised to call on the one
above all the only being capable of
reforming the earth one 4209 reality
traveling beyond all space and time to
the realm of the one above all proper
because the original living tributyl had
been destroyed Thanos presents an offer
to allow Adam warlock to become the New
Living Tribunal and exchange for the
recreation of Earth one 4209
reforming reality at the moment before
its destruction where the events played
out and seeing Adam warlock and Thanos
reviving that universes hero population
and defeating Annihilus at the story's
end jim Starlin revealed that adam
warlock
had now stepped into the role of the
Living Tribunal under the direction of
the one above all that said something I
want to point out here is that where
this is now the standard going forward
into the future of Marvel Comics on the
whole stalin's infinity series has never
really been considered can material
since all the stories took place outside
of the main Marvel kanu
meaning that at any point a new rider
could come along and retcon this
information establishing a new Living
Tribunal or even removing the element of
the one above all entirely but until
that happens for the moment at least the
one above all still exists the
destruction of the multiverse by the
beyonders was allowed due to the one
above all being curious as to how it
would reform and Adam warlock is now The
Living Tribunal with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I will catch you guys on it
peace